hello guys again today I mean second
time this time it's games of the week
games of the week lecture so for today's
for today's lecture games of the week I
decided to prepare and analyze two games
from the final match between Fabian
Carwin and Magnus Carlsen from the
clutch tres International which I mean
the basically the matchup is like number
one and number two in the world so it
was extremely interesting especially
after their first I mean like the match
the and the twelve draws and then in the
Thai breaks that Magnus one against
Fabiano it was I think their first kind
of like I'm actually a match even maybe
it was one earlier I'm not sure but I
just I feel I feel like it was very very
interesting and I was excited to see it
and myself so again we had in those
games there were many opening novelties
domain opening new opening trends and
stuff I decided to prepare the last two
clutch games the wharf-boat warp 3
points and I just thought that you know
they were the most critical to the
entire match especially now that before
the last before the first clutch game
Magnus was leading but Fabiana managed
to win the first game and Magnus was
forced to win on demand the last one so
I was thinking that both games will be
extremely interesting because both sides
were under pressure to win their games
because otherwise they would measure be
simply over so let's get started because
there were the games were very
interesting so for the first one
Fabian was playing with wider guys - so
it was a 45 93 96 of course mine was
going for special new curve the same
just like in the match World
Championship match 2018 and Fabiano
typically goes for rasoolum oh we should
before we shall be five and in the match
the first game of the match in 2018
Magnus played g6 later in San Luis rapid
and blitz man who's played ecigs also we
played six many times in the previous
games against the Fabiano in this clash
final but in this game he decided to
play e5 and e5
this is already here if I also Mongoose
tried against Fabiana in one of the
previous games in the clutch in the in
there match during this clutch final how
quickly also showed this game because in
this game how to put it
Magnus I'm sorry Fabiano didn't choose
the most let's say critical approach and
this one he actually did so I guess he
did some homework meantime between the
runs or something I don't know me or me
he recalled his analysis or I know I
just thought that this was let's say a
core I'd approach this line so a short
Castle Bishop d6 and right now in the
first one sorry in this game
her father Fabian played c3 and the
first game that they played was
different with d3 but I feel like -
comfortably equalized here and
eventually got very very good position
so in the game happened 96 Bishop g5 h6
wish average for a 6 we should see for
Bishop e7 and actually as position
reminds me a lot about some Italian but
with the difference that pawns on c5 not
on c7
I think Italian would be like eternal
game with one c7 in the exact same
position but here maybe it's up on a
single with us as a pawn d6
so it's pretty similar but Heuer or a
policy five and very often involves
positions actually Blackwood is well
placed on see if I because it controls
more of a center and it makes it harder
for for--why to play d4 so in this game
I feel like Magnus equalized quitted
pretty comfortably and after 63 or shut
Castle Knight B to D 6a for nine h5
Bishop g3 g6 all those moves were pretty
natural and I don't think that Magnus
have had any problems I feel like he
quickly around here to cover the
initiative and when we need eventually
the game so but let's not discuss this
just want to quickly bring it up in
order to show what happened with their
previous encounter in this line so right
now my violin played C free and this is
more critical because immediately the
ideas to play d4 man who's played a six
and right now I mean it spins there are
many games actually here but I was
pretty surprised to discover that you
know it's not so popular move e5 like
normally when people play this rustling
they play either Jesus or ecigs is there
are two most popular moves but if I is
not so popular but there have been some
games late here as well actually so C 3
a 6 and right now there have been right
now Fabian played Bishop a4 which is the
best move however there are alternatives
I'll just quickly to cover them if let's
say Bishop d3 where their Bishop c2 and
before it doesn't bring much because I
have 6 let's say Michelle c2 and short
Castle and the thing is that d4 doesn't
bring much because after d40x before it
takes d4 nothing sorry it takes e4
Knight takes d4 9 24 Queen if with the
Queen takes d4 and now Queen c7 because
of this bishop on d6 pawn x2 is worse
than subject of the attack and also
bishop on c2 also runs under this
Queen and c7 so black simply wins upon
let's say if H free black can either
plate either take on c2 also it's
possible to play b5 with very good
position and simply this is just extra
point for for black of course white can
take on d5 but there you know at least
there is very good development advantage
with Bishop e6 also it could be some
moves like Knight x f2 sometimes they're
definitely worth attention there deserve
attention
so this basically black is doing very
well here Bishop d3 is therefore not not
really I think Bishop c6 played onions
query one of the top players so I
thought it could be interesting and at
the of the taxi after rejects it could
be would be just play d4 as quickly as
possible
after with a six black are not
developing really pieces so it makes
sense to take on such a you know let's
say aggressive approach and they you
know take play d4 and I the email is
create some in the center but actually
after Bishop takes c6 takes d4 it takes
d4 C takes D for Bishop g4 in the game
and give a report richer report is the
equalized and even was better in his
game so the game happened if v if
detects c5 Bishop c5 there is no problem
I know improvement for black positions
was really good the pair of bishops just
offers great chances for black in a
habit happen if five he takes Bishop d7
d takes e5 quint XD one rook takes d1
which she takes the frigate takes the
three and sixty five and I believe that
black is simply more comfortable here
because the bad pawn structure for for
white so this is not really a thing this
Bishop sistex either Bishop c4 finally I
follow also also also it's interesting
because put some pressure on f7 possibly
on the dinery we should be five as well
so but here also at nine f6 is pretty
much it is the equalizing let's save d4
City XD forty days before it takes d4
the only thing that right now black has
to memorize one line but if white black
memorizes is just simply very easy so if
that's a night xd4 then text acquisition
is always a problem for white black is
doing mentally well because after age
three let's say B 5 B should be seven
short Castle black has very good piece
play Bishop has to be five often d5 is
coming may come very quickly and it's
very good position for for black if
Knight c3 doesn't really change much we
of course we can't take on civil squint
HD six but like if you just play castle
first it's pretty much the same stuff
before vision p7 also a truth King right
now Bishop e5 similar stuff like is
doing generally well here if but only
thing what happens after if I because
this critical if if I've right now like
it's the only move Bishop takes d5
Knight takes d5 Knight takes e5 and
after Ruby one of course right now this
if d6 then F for simply is winning I'll
just quickly put on the board is simply
winning because there is the spin and we
can get we cannot save our Knight but in
this position there is no short castle
after short castle rook takes e5 there
is move here Queen c7 and after Quinta
is d4 there is move d5 and this is
actually very nice because suddenly both
bishops are hanging and there is no way
to to defend both because it's just such
a little bit weird pin pin on this C
file but basically black wins the pitch
bishop back and with total equality
basically without any problems so the
same thing happen happen let's say let's
say in this position after Bishop c4
Knight f6 a saber what tries with this
move but it's exactly the same story
exactly same story so let's say if
Quinte takes d4 d5 Knight c3 right now
between takes e4 they Rock takes d5 nice
tactical move we embarked upon takes
takes and right now let's say h6 Bishop
f4 which would be 6 this is
deadly equal position there is no way
that either of the side can really win
this you know realistically so it's just
equal so also Bishop c4 is not therefore
not that not sold on a good choice
whoever Bishop a4 and rather the right
after b5 mr. C 297 Fabian decide to play
d3 there have been many alternatives as
well
there is move a 4 there is move d4 I
don't want to dive into details but you
know I've personally it feels to me that
a 4 could be the most precise if a for
the thing is that if room p88 XB v 8x b
5 and d4 CTA is the fourth stage d4
Knight takes d4 Knight takes d4 it takes
d4 and right now if Queen takes d4 if
Queen takes d4 ran out after Queen c7 h3
the problem is for black that the pawn
on d5 is very often object of the attack
by the night and for instance if Bishop
d7 Knight c3 and the black has I mean
what has very simple development and
normally this Bishop e5 could be a
problem could be the idea but doesn't
really bring much because already pawned
if I was hanging and the white controls
the FL which is normally very good for
for white and the thing is that if if d4
will happen is the exactly same line but
it's less good for for black for white
because after let's say h3 Bishop d7
earlier would nice if it was very good
right now if Knight c3 is not so good
because of before and pollinate six
covers be five square so this is a huge
difference that's why a four out play a
four at first but probably the it's
quite a new line so probably the fear we
will we start developing here so we can
possibly if Fabiano plays against manage
this again or more like magnetized on
the 3/5 here again against
Fabiano maybe you will see new you know
index games maybe you can see like
development interfere here for now
fabian 2396 but i think that this is
pretty much calm approach where black
should be doing quite well maybe it's
around equal maybe why study better it's
difficult to say it's kind of typical
let's say lopez / italian position
structure / structure which is you know
depends depends on the perspective and
you know depends also on the style of
players who play who was what was going
on there and but personally objectively
it feels to me the block should be doing
quite well therefore I think that this a
forum was the most testing well anyway
the free and I just think we should be
free short castle in IBD - we should be
seven and right now Bishop b3 played
Fabiano I just play Bishop d5 very
logical d6 Bishop g5 and right now I not
entirely sure whether I like Marcus move
because he play Queenie yet and I'm not
entirely sure whether this is correct or
not it's definitely possible but I was
wondering what's wrong with quizzes so
it just seems like it's a little bit
more natural and I understand it could
be some problems of the Cephas sometimes
like here sa rockz one would be a
problem but after all we don't have to
take with the C pawn we can keep our
pawn on c5 and twelve-step we should be
seven and to be honest I don't really
see any problems here for black also the
fred is night before so if the say rooks
one could be met by the night before and
we tried basically votes Bishop screen
would be very well placed on b7 let's
say Roxy one time before Bishop takes
Queen takes I think that black is doing
quite well here so I don't really see a
problem of Queen system Queen c7 because
queen it's also possible was a little
bit extravagant I thought the Queen c7
is just just very simple with around
equality here but Magnus had different
parents or queen e8 before it takes the
464 and Ruby
as we see the difference in this
position we could have played easily
Bishop d7 with Queen and c7 we could
play a baby should be seven right now we
should be saying it's a little bit weird
because we are basically paying
ourselves with this Bishop on b7 so
makes no literally no sense so - player
B which is also very good move
Roxy one and right now - plays very very
good movement before I'm not saying that
this is better for white by enemies
Queeny it was also very legit move from
which - play I just personally my
personal preference here is Queen c7
like Queen only it is okay but the
squizzle looks much more natural this to
me but 28 this is also fine for black
ruby 8 and right now
rook c1 this is the critical position
you want to critical positions and
managed correctly chose play and played
here night before hitting on this Bishop
on d5 may prefer think 93 and c4 pretty
much very good move the alternative
would have been to play c4 but right now
this was clearly worse for for black
because of which of taxi six a very
important move Queen takes c6 d5 Queen
c7 and right now be free basically white
undermines the pawn on c4 and basically
entire pawn chain on the Queen side so
if c3 right now before and position wise
I feel like West pushes preferable
because positive free is very likely to
be lost and it's much easier to play
this position with Y rather rather
rather than with black of course black
can hope for some conversation here for
this pawn because the extra further
because of the pair of bishops and
potential let's say f5 and stuff like
this but it's I don't have really two
big faith in this overall I believe what
should be studied better here
so night before was a very good move D
takes e5 d takes d5 Bishop takes d5 and
finally we got to the most important
position
this game pretty much is the critical
position of this game because right now
Magnus made a huge mistake after which
Fabiana took over the initiative and
took over and basically almost didn't
let Magnus out even for a second
but why I say almost we'll see this in a
wizard soon because I'm gonna show one
position where actually Magnus had a
great chance to complicate things like
crazy for for Fabiano but he didn't do
it so but I would all gather in moment
so we shot xt5 happened in the game and
right now a man who's play Knight takes
d5 which is a big mistake
after he takes d5 Bishop 65 rook takes
d5 - is simply pawn down after we should
be 793 there is no enough conversation
just extra pawn for white and simply
just lost position for four Magnus maybe
still not lost maybe there are still
some chances practical chances but like
overall there is no conversation for
respond so 90s affair was a big mistake
instead I analyzed v65 rook takes e5 and
I thought this is this was much more
natural and right now there were two
good moves for black and both were
leading to extremely complicated
positions and turbulence I'm not sure
what's going on because it's just so
complicated
possibly positioned just around equal
with correct play so 93 is one move
which is very logical to hit on this
woman's if I present a knight xb2
and second move is neither for both and
basically snide after 1994 idea of 94 is
to bring this just 9 improve this night
bring it to the closer take King side
and try to look for some attack or like
just compensation for for the pawn that
was just you know lost on c5 let's start
off 93 Ida free let's say I know if rook
c3 Knight takes B to Queen a one night X
by day for
I don't see any real problems here from
black I feel like positions as equal
black to do by the pond and this is just
just okay for for black so the only sort
of chance to play this for a win
supposed to be to play Roxy - after Roxy
- night before Roxy free I was thinking
but right now this is just much worse
worse because Roxy five just not be free
but this is it just could be repetition
so after rook c3 Knight takes d5 it
takes d5 Bishop d7 this is much worse
version of what what happened in the
game because in the game RuPaul won't
suffice always a party policy d5 and
right now this pawn d5 is very likely to
be to be lost because it you know black
and very cool to play room DNI the four
and this rogue is not supporting spawns
it still black has to White has to spend
one Tempe to defend this pawn so I feel
like black has good compensation for
this pawn here and position just around
equal another movies here is not a four
which also would lead to lots of
complications and especially like in
rapid chess this would probably cause
you know possibly some practical
problems for Fabiano so let's say not be
free alternative could be the same
Knight d4 and after 94 the idea is let's
say to play Knight to to f3 and kind of
like put the sunrise and center but
right now black has very interesting try
rogue b6 and bring the rook to the for
the six rank to the King side Knight to
f3 to say Queen seven Queens c1
everything comes with Tempest 9 PG free
Roxy 7 Quinn d8 Queen c2 and Bishop g4
and the idea which she still is there
but position is just extremely
complicated so I'm clear that you know
anything can basically happen black has
definitely good conversation for this
for respond so this this would this was
better for black this was what black
should have done either here is 94 or
here 93 but it might be free here 9 for
9 be free F or just Bishop e6 is decent
and this is just you know this is just
pretty much equal position
there is no way that you know what could
be better here because just you know
equal material pretty much very balanced
position so this was where Magnus made a
mistake Bishop takes e5 and right now he
played Knight takes d5 instead if he is
just taken and either 94 93 he should be
pretty good so but he played Knight
takes d5 and right now
Fabiana didn't let my my moves out even
for for a moment almost but because
there was actually one known were favela
made a big mistake
so visual text e5 rook takes d5 we
should be 793 all correct right now
Queen d7 possibly quindi a was a little
bit more accurate because after Queen d7
there is 95 Queen D it prevents that but
still Queen d2 rook c8 let's say this
this 95 anyway gets their positions
pretty much nearly hopeless just pawn
extra pawn for white and very very
likely just winning position they gave
up in 2795 Bishop a 896 and I just get
to the perfect square and I rook e8 94
there were alternatives but Fabiano's
approach was very very good as well
Queen d6 before supporting the rook Ruby
for Queen a free RP 895 27 and this is
disposition this was actually a first
moment where Fabiano could have painted
b8 and this was just winning nearly on
the spot it was a little bit complicated
right now by b8 of course ruby is
queenie for wins on the spot so if Queen
a7
this was probably a little bit
complicated to find over the board
because right now Quincy free f6 and d6
is just very strong we just have to
leave this knight on b8 and there is
nothing that black could can do because
ruby is met by Roxy 7 and Queen b8 is
met by D 7 simply and this is just game
over
but could be could be hard to find let's
say at the board especially you know
under such amount of stress as the card
came with it so give
is not not the best not about either way
another web of either way h6 less h4
King h8 Magnus just stays in place 90
free just improving the position all
everything correct King g8 look c1 bring
the route again perfect technique
night of 895 9 h 7 tribe - try to bring
this knight to f6 to create some
pressure on d5 form but you know it's
let's say decent practical chance but
still is just lost and right now my
Fabiano was just winning would not be it
immediately
do we just curtains just 1 0 in military
because after Queen 87 there is simply
rook c8 and there is nothing that Magnus
could do Queenie 4 is a big Fred right
now so if visual takes d5 anyway Queen
takes d4 wins because of her days this
night of age takes Queen ba and finally
move in very poor move rook c8 and this
is just came over and I I don't think
it's a very very complicated line to
find especially that night b8 Roxy you
sort of can't stop calculating you just
kind of like you see that it should work
like generally should work because 24 is
just a big fret such a big Fred that you
know it just seems like it's
overwhelming at least also it could be a
good trend playing ib8 good after Queen
87 at least if you don't believe in Roxy
later you can always come back 96 and at
least good testing move for you know
good testing move what could do in order
to test whether black can you know can
play Queen 87 which is the best move or
maybe something else and we know the
spot so might be able simply winning
that's just basically came over there is
nothing that black can do but instead
Fabian team human King g2 and this is a
big mistake like I was surprised to
realize this and but it actually it
nearly froze all of the advantage what
still is somewhat better here but it
leads to right now the position can
easily get out of hand the thing is
Fabian here had like a few minutes like
maybe unknown three four minutes or
maybe - I don't remember exact
me and my man was playing on increment
like it's five second increment that
they had so of course like if you play
kingi - of course I'm gonna play the
same you like engage I try to you know
just wait it out but the thing is after
thi thing I'd be right now finally if I
when I played it and this is just came
over because they repeated once and now
that takes a six and this is just you
know few moves happened and just you
know game over
this is just you know taking b7 you know
anything wins so this is how the game
ended but in this position after King
dick - suddenly Magnus could have I
think I'm not entirely sure but like I
think he could have made me save the
game and even if not save the game he
definitely could put much much tougher
resistance to Fabiana and the best move
was to play g6 and this is actually me
think about is pretty logical because
strategically of course black is lost
completely lost pawn down much worse
pieces the only sort of hope for black
in to save this game would be to create
some mess I'm you know muddy the waters
that create some complications the only
way otherwise just came over and this is
what happened the game that he played
King h8 he didn't do anything special
suddenly can i b8 and this was over so
if you play here g6 you are attacking
this night on night on f5 right and it's
not so not so clear what to do here
because the same night goes out of the
FI the signal goes to e3 the copy place
for instance a smooth like Queen d6 and
if I get or maybe even King g7 if I
bring my knight to f6 and I try and
respond if I it could be extremely
complicated to win this with with white
even though it's so nicely placed
everything so now it's just a by far the
critical the most critical of perfect
King g7 something that has no no squares
to go right because on f5 is covered in
g4 is covered if something is covered as
well so seemingly what is just losing
ever the piece but the thing is that
still White has
such a good position here tonight there
is an ID it again working and ib8
Queen b7 still right now both Knights
are under attack and Knight takes a six
and this point the idea is that there is
97 7 coming and the Queen I think is
impossible because it's hanging on f7 as
well but actually no sorry
Quincy this is possible but it's not fun
not by far not easy to realize the end
one sense only position gets completely
wild and on the increment and should be
based in time travel it can go simply
either way in such position so right now
black has two moves in a row noble 7
trying to cover a 7 or play Queen takes
a 6 so I feel like Group E 7 is is
inaccurate because after let's say Roxy
6 King dies h6h 5 white maintains the
strong attack and what should eventually
win however is again by far not so clear
over the board when you see it because
takes takes the scene at c5 Queen H
freak
satellites are not easy to let's say
find and the real understand during the
game especially that here the exchanges
loss on c6 there could be some rookie to
some activity and so on maybe we haven't
tried to take this pawn to c6 it you
know there are some practical definitely
some practical chances for black even
though objectively what should be
winning anyway but you know at least
from practical perspective as I said it
offers much tougher resistance here for
for black rather than what man is dead
in the game
another possibility here is just even
stronger is Quint xa6 after Queen takes
f7 king tides h6 rooks e6 seemingly
white just let's say I mean takes takes
either queen or one either with the
Queen and I 6 or just check me on g6 but
after Queen TC 6 sorry Quint x6 the
Texas 6 is simply pawn is also very
strong language so it's horrible but
let's move rook ecigs
which is just you know computer chess
obviously but it suddenly can save the
game or nearly save the game like know
what course was the better but like
it's not so clear because rope a six the
rook takes a six suddenly Knight will
have the score of six point deep one is
stopped and you know can go either way
so the best chance I follow this route
86 but after up to 86 of course the
existing squint X is six ways for black
so what has to go for this route I see
six detects is 6 and quiz is six and
suddenly you know it can can go eat
again either way like I mean you cannot
go either way black definitely cannot
win this because it seems so bad but
definitely there are big chances for
notice because there are always some
perpetual tracks possible let's say I
know and if let's say King gauge tours I
mean there is the same of Queen d5 or
maybe Quincy for trying to pin the pawn
and the Queen and the Queen let's say go
somewhere then the nine maybe can join
the game and you know it let's say black
stabilizes and you know who knows what's
gonna happen it's pretty much completely
new game and anything can happen I
believe the white still somewhat better
but is by far not not clear what's going
on here whatsoever
so g6 would have led to complete the
wild game and who knows who knows what
would have happened so this what makes
that the only moment were Fabiana made
this mistake of King g2 in certain areas
just means the game on the spot so but
after risking g8 working-age ni b8 this
is how the game ended and you know very
nice win by Fabiano in general apart
from this moved into two which was which
would nearly blow which could blow their
load the game so this is this is it for
this game let's that's how Fabiano one
very nice game and let's see how Magnus
managed to make a make a big comeback in
the next game which is
the following was the following one so C
45 93 96 g3 Bishop before Magnus sticks
with his English and right now before
this is the same move that Marcus played
against Fabiano in World Championship
match in the tiebreaks so I'll just
quickly bring this game because in the
tiebreaks I think Fabien was surprised
and in the game happened in this game
have an IG show castle IJ - one more
thing
normally people play here bigger object
to share custody for but the thing is
that after Bishop takes free it is
considered that black is doing quite
well however if we start with E for sure
castle we can start right off 9je - and
if we should take Sofia we always take
the knight totus Tuus III and this is
this should be good for white does the
entire idea of tanky for first of course
this gives possible to take here on C
free immediately and we'll discuss in a
moment but after a short Castle Knight G
to c6 this will happen in the their
first match in the world fair first game
in the World Championship match in the
you know in a tie-break Bishop g2 a6 is
a little bit inaccurate so castle b5 and
right now first remove d4 and ever since
since this moment - seize the initiative
and comfortably I believe so
one the game because right now he got
this bone structure extra the pair of
bishops and this extra pawn for black is
not really relevant after this in this
endgame pretty much every all the time
in charge here I remember in this
position
Knight b7 was the best move it was
pretty much still some chances and
possibly a clear position but my fabian
played made a mistake would I be 5000 a
c5 this was pretty much very very bad
for for black here so anyway I believe
in this position why definitely has very
good chances so it's not that it's not a
surprise that Magnus repeats this line
so often Bishop takes c3 and right now
detective free is the most popular one
but B takes c3
Mangusta chose for this game is lamb
much less explored and you know if he
wanted to kind of create some game and
get some you know winning chances some
basically practical chances some game
basically going on B texif is pretty
much the right let's say a approach to
do it because you know it's bliss to
more unexplored terrain sands and so on
so shot castle f3 and right now the idea
here for white in general is to play
let's say 9 h 3 9 f to maybe play d4 at
some point and try to you know build
strong center and maybe get to a4 at
some point in general try to make good
use of that pair of bishops by creating
hopefully your Sun your attack on the
kingside or some pressure in the center
and openness and eventually and make use
of their pair of bishops so having said
that my Papillon decided to play
immediately move b5 which is by the way
I think that a free move right now is in
novelty if I'm not mistaken a phrase
novelty Bishop g2 was still transposed
to the other line but a free I think in
special is a novel
but if I win right now play move b5
which is extremely interesting and what
did we win to ask ourselves what does it
do and the answer is it simply
challenges white center considering that
black hasn't developed what sir what has
developed any of the pieces yet there on
the back rank while black king is
already saved on the kingside and is
developed and if black can quickly get
so custom action the center black will
be definitely black will be definitely
doing well alternative could be let's
say rook e8 which is also which also
makes a lot of sense and right now I
unless funny move King f2 can you have
to of idea of playing simply let's say
after g6 let's say going for g4
immediate attack and who knows maybe
this is what bands have played would
have played in 92 there are days also 92
93 h4 maybe d4 and this pawn chain of
ponds before a free g4 is pretty much
giving quite solid centre and white can
hope to create some attack on the on the
King side of course questions completely
an export there have been known games
like this no games like this and I think
that in the there could be some you know
new new theories to be easily be
developing here especially the Magnus
point for it so b5 before let's say it's
beat x4 g5 analyzed and this positions
pretty much completely unclear and I
would assume that Magnus was hoping for
something like this I don't know if b5
was came as a surprise to manager or not
but he played before which is by far the
best move the thing is if seat XB v
d5 and this is exactly what black ones
after d3 let's say trying to establish
under black continues the approach of
sacrificing i mean keeping this pawn
being pink kind of like pawn down but
the whole piece to the game so this is
one possibility and all possibly a6
both moves are pretty good and both lead
to completely let's say unclear
positions let's say after a six other
personal ethics or just stick with this
you'll be takes a cig let's say Bishop
takes a six
knowledge 3c5 is possible also c5
immensely is possible to postpone take
only six but right now this point simply
irrelevant back has very good
development advantage and development of
pieces it's an adage frequently five
analyzed Bishop d2 c4 again challenge
the challenge in the center text md5
Bishop h6 9f2 2526 policy for is pretty
much lost extra point for white three
extra two points right now don't matter
because point c4 is lost and this extra
point which will be the suffer be should
be - Bishop c4 takes takes will not be
really relevant because white black
species activity is just so so big also
black and postpone taking on c4 but
playing 97 96 at first so I feel like
it's just very very good position for
black so therefore C takes d5 is too
greedy c5 is also possible but again
just d5 takes takes it so text b5 Queen
a 5 let's say qui and if Queen a for
Queen c7 very very strong move and again
this pieces blacks black as compensation
for a pawn because of the prospects in
the center partly in d5 and the fact
that white pieces are still not
developed fully yet so for instance
analyze Bishop f3 trying to stop d5 rook
the 890 to d5 it takes d5 Knight takes
d5 all this pawn structure is pretty
sorry maybe put red marker all the
search is pretty weird and I feel like
black has very good position here so C
file also not great therefore - played D
for which is very strong move it takes
d4 C takes d4 bit XC for b5 by far the
strongest move because if Bishop c4
probably 35 will just is just great for
black let's say it takes d5 Knight takes
d5 this d5 square for the knight is just
very powerful if we can even trade the
bishops black will be just much better
maybe not much aware but clearly better
if 595 and right now this is the first
Greek opposition I'm
sure if Fabiana become mixed up his
lines or something because the pressure
he prepared although all of this but
right now I feel like a rookie aids them
web is the best move and the idea behind
Ruby 8 is that right now there is no
better Moodle King f2 because if black
can play d6 right now next move and
challenge the center you know for
instance Bishop c4 d6 it was 92 D takes
e5 immediate black change the center and
there is no no any problems here
whatsoever for dragons just extra pawn
what make up for some conversation but
it just it just hopes there is no really
big conversation for for this forest
pond so King f2 F what is the best move
but right now after 95 Bishop 6496 next
and next d6 the difference is the
gratitude what happened they came White
King is on f2 and black Ruby devil or 88
so this inclusion of working f2 a rookie
is definitely in blacks favor so for
instance I analyze Q bishop differ
Bishop b3 if let's say we should be free
d6 for Bishop h6 if takes takes let's
say neither free and right now night
before for instance looks very good for
black trying to get to the gunite from a
6 to d5 and I feel like of course place
is pretty much still unclear but I feel
like drag is doing quite well
definitely no any problems especially
that you know Fabiana won the first game
first Cubs game and this is not what
Marlins would like to play for a win
here I have my suspicions only but what
I think if Bishop b3 makes a bit more
sense because visual basics never attend
never will trade the could the bishops
but right now again d6 and let's say if
F 496 93 Bishop g4 this position is very
clear again but it seems to me that
black is doing quite well for if Bishop
e3 Knight 95 let's say no to Knight see
for this King 1 f2 is always a problem
and the black in general should be able
to put some pressure in the center
other possibilities would be h3 but then
we shall take the freaking tags of free
king takes up three because if Queen
Queen f3 of course not XD four wins
so King take index of 3 Queen d7
thus King on f3 is you know not very
comfortable right and over the next
let's say move rook 88 and T takes e4
now will come to d4 c5 black has very
very good play I believe I'm not saying
that black is better but definitely
black doesn't have any real anywhere
near real major problems so Bishop III
let's say Knight a5 Bishop c2 9 AC for
changing this Bishop on on the e3 with
some queen c6 next possibly maybe
detects if v and org 88 next move many
many possibilities for black if Kim G -
of course if we came back and take this
Bishop will be such such nice island is
such nice knight on d5 definitely no
problems at all so I just think that
this position is just very very very
good for black and that's why I would
suggest playing here I was black rook
yet there were no games like this but
only my assumption would be that if the
the figuri will develop eventually it
would develop here with after rook e8
because after Knight 95 immediately
Bishop c4 it's not so so easy I believe
because 9 piece maybe 6 probably still
the best move and try to play d6 but the
difference is that right now white King
can still castle right so let's say
Bishop d3 d6 Queen c2h6 analyzed and
this position is pretty much unclear
like Knight c4 is this is just very
unclear position and to be honest I am
not sure who is better here possibly is
just equal it's difficult to analyze
this I didn't want to get dive into too
deep this lines because you know it's
just so unclear and there are also other
lines they want to cover especially the
previous game so you know I just had to
limit
you know what I'm talking about today
but anyway this is this was very likely
very good for for black but in also
leading to completely unclear positions
if we shall be free knight c6 f for
Bishop h6 is again you know Bishop on
stops take King side taking from custom
taking side we show a 3d six the idea is
in general for black to change the white
center and if they were black can do it
good way like we're doing right now and
I believe that black has very good
position in general all the time while
black wants to play on the light squares
could taking good making good use of
this core on d5 and very often also c4
so I feel like this position just pretty
much unclear black has to be let's play
white has played as a king of two
buttons desi for Queen d3 g 6 crook a g1
to say oh no not good question let's say
rook f e8 maybe look a d8 preparing you
know moves like c5 actually I think
about quitted also it makes sense
because just projects I know Bishop on a
695 is the fret so it's also not so easy
to play this position with white it can
easily turn around and what could be
simply better here so diabetes I think
again a little bit more accurate but we
should be seven is it's also okay but
right now I feel like white is slightly
better after 9h free afternoon mb6 blog
will be basically doing well after
Bishop d7 at age three I feel like
position is sort of you know leading
leaning towards towards white evaluation
so d6 it's still not nothing bad but you
know it's little bit you know more
pleasant place especially white the six
short Castle and the alternative would
be the sake windy free and idea of
course 95 and I think this was maybe a
little more accurate however is by far
not clear h6 will be one let's say
Bishop c6
short Castle the takes e5 d takes e5 90
senses will
if Mitchell takes d5 95 and or in
certain ethics if I've even so if rookie
one rook e8 f4 and right now Knight to
b6 in all most positions black tries to
play on the light squares which very
often gives good counter play and this
is please positions under this position
is not an exception black should be
doing quite well however bishop after
this this and f2 you see the difference
in the previous positions the King was
easily on if it was on f2 and was easily
attacked right now his safety on psyphon
g1 on the King side and the wide manage
to develop all the pieces and definitely
not so easy to play this position
however still I believed what I should
be doing quite okay but if I have to
choose size right now I would choose
white so Quinn d3 was possibly a little
bit better alternative it doesn't mean
that you know it like gives certain
advantage but you know it's definitely
move deserves attention - plate right
now circus which also is a very good
move
97 rook e1 just building I mean
strengthening the centre D takes e5 d
takes e5 and this is the first critical
position while with the first one out of
two critical positions in this game
because right now what could do nice
here with with black it's you know like
95 King went to do something about it so
Fabian decides to play the most let's
say natural move which is Knight 7 to b6
and this is definitely a good move
however I personally believe that Queen
7 is even stronger
we 7 is stronger in my opinion because
first of all crazy fret now sorry Queen
taxi 525 check winning the piece and
let's say back what can do deal with in
many ways I thought the best one of the
two most natural ways is to play either
Bishop takes d5 accept the challenge and
take this knife or play Queen D for
covering c5 square so let's say first 24
if 2496 let's say Bishop F 1 and right
now I feel like if after f6
would be like would be doing quite well
we should f3 would run into all sort of
like moves like Bishop g5 and I'm not
entirely sure what if what has you know
if Black has enough if black is doing
well here because for instance Queen c5
is running runs into Quincy 595 and
Bishop e7 and this is a big problem for
for black and if not Quincy 5 let's see
Quincy the night of four comes with 10
piece among any many other problems in
this position I said then Bishop h3
Bishop e7 stuff like this just really
really dangerous so f pad here instead
of this f6 I feel like it's very strong
putting some pressure on this on the
center if is 695 so f4f what is the
decent move but right after takes takes
this Bishop right now is perfect to
perfectly support the Queen side but if
we can remove this and by sacrificing
the exchange this Queen comes to c6 and
black has very very strong conversation
for the sacrifice material so this would
this would be my suggestion here what to
do with black pieces if B should be free
just quickly show our cookies no c5 and
let's say Bishop g5 and right now for
this powerful move Queenie six which is
actually nice nice idea is this and this
pretty much leads to equal endgame but
equal but still pretty much on clear
black has definitely some chances also
white has some chances you know this but
you know the thing is that I believe
that this this was the right path for
for black 1996 is also okay I'm not
saying it's not but Kristin was level
more accurate and I will see more in a
moment why after Knight b6 we should be
free right now my Fabian made big
mistake because he played move 27 of the
Queen seven his position is nearly
nearly lost only move was here to play
c5 after c5 Bishop f3 c 4 which would
activate and right now yeah basically if
everyone had to sacrifice
the exchange if he didn't if he doesn't
do it he's pushing just very very bad
so c4 we should take the White Queen
takes f8 Bishop c2 and right now let's
quit c5 everything comes pretty much
force 9 f 293 queen bee 1 takes takes
and which legs f3 and I believe in this
position black has good conversation for
the exchange and it was the best what
Fabiano could achieve here after
midnight 7 to be 60 South Queen 7
basically has to for sacrifice the
exchange and you know like maybe there
is conversation ok outside is there is a
very conversation but how big of a
conversation it is in the real practical
game is another question definitely
black has some chances to win this
because of the extra exchange and if we
can let's a place table is positive
Quincey freak when you free maybe bring
the rook somehow maybe blockaded
priciple of the night to see free there
definitely you know some sometimes for
white to win this however with correct
play black should eventually be alright
but from practical perspective Queen 7
was just much stronger so here
Fabiano made big mistake which is queen
7 after this move and eat 6 which Magnus
player viously position is just nearly
nearly lost
Fabiana took we just which only hastens
things because after F takes is 695
pushes just lost pyramids were f6 or
rook e8 either one of them but none of
them really solve a problems because for
instance after f6 a4 a5 a4 trying to
play a 5 ourselves so black has to play
a 5 that's another for Vogue FDA Queen
e2 its policies just so powerful that
strategically in all most positions
while it's just much better it's just
huge advantage other if let's say rook
e8
Queen c2 again f6 we are nearly forced
everywhere to play this is just really
really bad so and finally rook f e8 same
thing this pond a4 a5 idea is quite
quite typical
and in this position again policies
remains and is just just overwhelming
nearly overwhelming is just very bad
position for black but anyway it was
sort of a must when I had to do instead
he took but after Knight g5 it's just
all collapsing because of this sorry not
this not this not this arrow because of
this Queen c2 and those ideas here are
like you know and also this Bishop here
as well this diagonal it's simply
geometrically geometrically very bad
position for for black in the game
happily f6 and go after Queen c2 let's
say if g6 Reina we should be to can just
join the game of winning position after
room g6 very nice tactics by by Magnus
route 86 and this is just just game over
so probably had to give the Queen but
you know it just doesn't really help
should be for King h8 Queen a5 pretty
good technique by Magnus Bishop Ave
right now I just want to check two
checks and this is just reasonable and
here Fabiana resigned so just to wrap it
up this game it was after a first loss
Magnus had to basically go all then you
know we win or I mean here to basically
win this game and right now in this
position he got very good position kind
of like from the practical point of view
because it was completely unexplored I
work he managed to outplay Fabiano
however objectively I as I as I shot
here with Bishop sorry in here with rook
e8 I feel like Fabian have had gotten
out of the opening very good position
also if 95 here ideas of Knight b6 in
general and this immediately also would
have given object of the good position
but you know it's just like we can
always say if he did that you know would
be different but like you know it's it's
it's hard to see Z to discuss after the
fact while
during the game you you know it's not so
easy you know decision-making and so on
so we can't Chris as Fabiana about you
know his choices here because especially
again especially against manuscripts no
world champion so it's not it's not it's
not shame to lose to lose to maxims of
course so night see business seven to be
six and only here last month was Queen
seven was and to write idea I don't
bother at the wrong time because hip
just play c5 here was you know by very
very good chance for justice for black
to let's say maintain the say rotten
balance because this position exchange
down would have would have been would
have been let's say definitely some
conversation for for Fabiano but he
didn't do it he instead played queen so
in the wrong moment and after this is
just really really bad right so this
this is day at the end of this game and
I hope you enjoyed my analysis and
commentary I will see you next time
thank you bye
you